welcome
thanks for joining us to review what's
new and what's next with infrastructure
for ai and ml
i'm chelsea chop product manager for
compute engine within google cloud and
i'm joined today by omkar pathik
product manager for cloud tpus within
google
first we'll review our accelerator
mission
ai and ml within google
how we're able to provide you with the
differentiated compute platform
and the ways to take advantage of our
accelerator hardware then we'll focus on
our accelerator hardware platform
cloud gpus and cloud tpus
we'll cover what's new and what's next
in the portfolio and sprinkle in ways
that our customers are creating
innovative products and services
within google cloud
at google cloud we believe that cutting
edge machine learning infrastructure
should excel at performance
scalability and usability to allow you
to be able to create innovative and
differentiated services for your users
all at a low total cost of ownership
our leadership in ai through both google
research
deepmind
and also in the practical applications
of ai within our google products
allow us to be able to provide you with
an innovative platform for your ai and
ml use cases
we bring our experience of deploying ai
and ml models in production across all
of google and provide you with the same
infrastructure and tools that we use
this means we have accelerators for any
of your use cases from high performance
training to serving models cost
effectively
you are able to achieve the optimal
price per performance for your use case
through our selection of cloud gpus
cloud tpus as well as compute optimized
vms on compute engine
this gives you the ability to choose the
latest and greatest infrastructure to
fit your use case needs
last and arguably most important for you
is that it's easy to get started and to
scale using a wide range of tools and
services offered through compute engine
and vertex ai platform
allowing you to create business value
faster
it really helps to partner with
companies that have fully deployed ai
and ml in their own production
environments
to help you overcome roadblocks faster
we have a long history of hardware
development
and we're always dedicated to being an
open cloud allowing you a diversity of
options from frameworks to application
portability
we're at a really exciting time in the
world for ai and ml every industry will
soon be transformed
the organizations that embrace the iml
in this transformation will have a
competitive advantage
to unlock the full value of ai ml we
must first focus on your business
challenges
we're able to do that in two progressive
ways
first you can focus on common business
challenges
shown here are the common business
challenges by industry along with the
solutions that we've created to help you
easily get started
then moving on you're able to solve
challenges that are unique to your
business
the following solutions services apis
and models
all help with ai needs at every single
level of expertise and readiness
you really don't need to be an ml expert
to get started we have easy to use apis
or automl models that allow you to
create
a customized solution to your unique
business challenges
you can plug and play the apis and
models to create exactly what you need
underneath this entire portfolio are our
hardware accelerators cloud tpus cloud
gpus and compute engine
there's three main ways to take
advantage of accelerators on google
cloud
first via vertex ai offering end-to-end
ai ml tooling and scheduling
via gke using containers enabling gpus
and tpus as a service
removing the burden from you to manage
the hardware the vms for your ai
workload simply give your containers
access to gpus via the kubernetes api
and then you're able to take advantage
of auto scaling see the gpu utilization
and scale these workloads up and down
based on the demand
last also via compute engine
we offer custom vm shapes
tooling and workflow support
for you to be able to scale from a
single gpu under your desk
to super computer computing scale
available on demand with preemptable
instances as well as committed use
discounts based on reservations to get
you the best price
our virtual machines are available in
many configurations including predefined
sizes that align to numa topology or as
we mentioned prior the ability to create
a custom machine type size for your
specific needs
then you aren't having to manage a
single vm you're also able to use
managed instance groups in a way to
control an entire fleet of your
infrastructure
you're able to define a set of vms and
scale up and down as you need or as your
application requires
now let's dive into what's new with
cloud gpus
within our cloud gpu portfolio we have
an accelerator for your use cases from
ml training and inference
gpu-enabled
hpc
cuda compute
and gpu accelerated visualization
our high-end offerings include
high-performance gpus a100s and b100s
that are great for training
inference hpc and cuda compute
on the other end of the spectrum we have
tp4s which are in more global locations
providing you
low latency at a very low cost
a very common use case that we see with
our customers is training and doing
inference on a100s or v100s and then
serving in that global capacity on t4s
let's take a closer look at our a100
offering
they're available in our accelerator
optimized vm family a2s on compute
engine
the a100s have 40 gigabits of memory and
within the vm you can provision up to 96
cascade lake ecpus
and 1.3 terabytes of memory
they're in fixed vm shapes to align with
the new transparent pneuma topology
and they can scale up to 16 gpus for
scale up and scale out workloads such as
natural language processing and computer
vision
but don't worry if you don't need 16 you
can go all the way down to two gpus to
be able to easily get started
nd-link fabric is the all to all
connectivity with up to 9.6 terabytes
per second peak bandwidth
you also have access to advanced
networking as well as the option for
local ssd
with all these features you're able to
achieve up to 20 ops of int 8 all within
a single vm which is what i call mega
performance
as i mentioned earlier t4s on google
cloud are able to provide a low latency
at a low cost
they're currently in 18 regions with
more along the way
what's new is that we do have flexible
t4s in preview currently
you can provision exactly what you need
for t4s from vcpu and vm memory
we're also launching automatic cub
renewals committed use discounts for
gpus this helps reduce costs and
accidental loss of your reservations
now here's what's really going to make a
difference for you for being able to
easily find capacity in your selected
region for batch workloads
are
we have distribution shapes within
manage instance groups set to any the
way you're able to take advantage of
this is in three very simple easy steps
first create a manage instance group
second set the distribution shape to any
and three specify your target audience
and region
optionally you can also run preemptable
gpus vms to save money
you can take note of any constraints
that you have such as supported hardware
in the zones or resource quotas to get
started
we also have the option for deep
learning and hpc vms that allows you to
easily get started on our infrastructure
within minutes
a simple one-click install and your
machine is provisioned and already
performance optimized on google cloud
it also has compatibility tested so you
have no need to worry about the software
stack
simply select the cpu gpu or tpu to add
on to the vm
we also provide the choice and
flexibility between different ml models
or you have the ability to install your
own
20 years team was looking for a cloud
provider that was just as committed to
advancing life sciences and drug
discovery as they were
that's why they chose google cloud
they also chose google because we're
known for our strength of our network
and our security posture
the partnership drastically changed the
way they were doing drug discovery
and as dr farad said this could
potentially potentially transform all of
the way that pharma is doing drug
discovery
as with any large resource intensive
models costas start to pile up
the price per performance worked really
well for them to create and discover
life-saving drugs to help combat covin
if they're able to do this cost
efficiently using
custom types of vms with gpus
then think about what you'd be able to
do with your workload
with the change in consumer behavior due
to coven
pagani was able to create a virtual
showroom to allow you to customize your
own car from the comfort of your couch
this virtual showroom is served on
nvidia t4s
with the nvidia rtx virtual workstation
image
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next let's pass it up to omkar to cover
cloud tpus what's new and what's next
take it away omkar
thanks chelsea
we have seen tremendous innovation in
the field of machine learning in the
past few years and we expect this rate
of innovation to grow in the future
however this fast-paced innovation
requires ever-increasing amounts of
computing power
as machine learning models get more
accurate they tend to get larger more
complex and require larger data sets
this is exactly why google built gpus
to accelerate the rate of machine
learning innovation by delivering high
performance ml training and serving at a
very low cost
tpus are used in many products at google
and it's likely that you have interacted
with these when you have used some of
google's products
these accelerators are available to you
in google cloud right now
our goal with tpus is to advance machine
learning at google and across the world
so tpus are built for this end-to-end
user journey of an ml developer or a
researcher starting from fast paced
iterative development in the beginning
all the way to large scale production
training and serving across a range of
machine learning use cases vision
language recommendations and more
it's also easy to get started with cloud
gpus with tensorflow pytorch or jax in a
google cloud project or a collab
you can also bring your own models or
use one of our reference models to get
started
what's even more interesting is that
once you get started with cloud tpus
it's easy to scale your machine learning
models on cloud tpu ports which means
that you can use petaflops of computing
power with minimal code changes
this image here shows a cloud tpu v3
port
which has 2048 cores that are built from
the ground up for machine learning
all of these cores are connected
together with a custom built super fast
interconnect which is really what
delivers that high performance when you
scale your machine learning models on
the cloud gpu pod
combined with the low cost of renting
cloud tpus on google cloud as opposed to
owning your own data centers
this high performance machine can unlock
completely new opportunities for
innovation without any upfront capital
investment on your part
to understand the power of easy
scalability
just look at our recent results in
mlperf
which is the industry standard benchmark
for ml performance
cloud tpus demonstrated leading
performance numbers across a range of
machine learning use cases and as you
can see in the chart here cloud tpus can
train some of the common machine
learning reference models in just a few
seconds
for example dlrm in 38 seconds or birth
in 17 seconds
we believe that this is incredibly
valuable especially since large-scale ml
training has unblocked some of the
recent breakthroughs in ai
for example lambda in natural language
processing or mum in multi-modal models
cloud tpus are particularly well suited
for these kinds of compute intensive
large scale machine learning workloads
over the last few years we have made
relentless progress on tpu hardware and
software and this year we are excited to
announce our latest generation cloud tpu
v4
on a chip to chip basis cloud gpu v4 is
more than twice as fast as its previous
generation
and at a broad scale
cloud tpu v4 pods take google cloud's
machine learning infrastructure to a
whole new level with more than one extra
flop of computing power
equivalent to more than 10 million
laptops combined
we have already deployed many of these
ports in google's data centers and will
soon have more
many of which will be operating at or
near 90 carbon free energy
cloud tpu v4 pods will be available to
our google cloud customers in preview in
q4 2021
now it's not just the sheer computing
power that pushes machine learning
innovation forward
we believe that making the system easy
to use is just as important as well
and so we recently launched a completely
new software architecture that helps you
interact much more easily and much more
seamlessly with cloud tpus
with cloud tpu vms you can now drive
full cloud tpu pods directly from your
desk for the first time
it's like having a machine learning
super computer under your desk
with cloud tpu vms we aim to make
interactive super computing attainable
to our users and it's been incredibly
encouraging to see positive feedback
from our early customers
for example hugging face which is a
leading open source provider of nlp
technologies recently integrated jax
along with tensorflow and pytorch in
their popular transformers library
and they were able to pre-train a base
size world model in less than a day with
just eight cores of v3
which is the smallest reservable unit of
a pod
similarly our users at grid space which
provides contact center automation tools
such as low latency speech analytics we
are able to train both speech and
language models with an immediate 2x
performance
improvement they were also able to scale
these models on cloud tpu pods with no
code changes
these usability and performance benefits
make it much easier than ever before to
get started with cloud tpus and scale
your machine learning models on cloud
tpu pods
along with this powerful user experience
cloud tpus also support all the major
machine learning frameworks including
tensorflow vitals and jacks
we encourage you to check out these
links and try out our reference models
and tutorials
in summary at google cloud we believe
that cutting edge machine learning
infrastructure should excel at
performance usability and scalability
so we'll continue to invest in making
our systems more easy to use enterprise
class and open and pervasive
hopefully with all of these updates on
cloud gpus and cloud tpus
our cutting-edge machine learning
infrastructure is much more accessible
and much more useful to you than ever
before
thank you
you